alan watt says this quote you can become
altogether so consumed with trying to
improve your life that you all together
forget to live it
and constantly believing that
joy or happiness or satisfaction
is to be found when i've done x
when i've completed y when i've achieved
zed it is a misnomer because tomorrow is
never
ever ever going to come it will always
continue to move away from you
and chasing that dragon of satisfaction
through productivity
it needs to be shortcuted it has to be
everybody that's listening anyone that's
a type a personality that's listening
who's constantly chasing that next thing
you have to find joy today and it's hard
i know it's hard because it feels like
by giving yourself that past
to say that it's enough to say that i've
i'm
satisfied i'm happy i'm grateful for the
things that i've done
our fear our internal fear is that
it's going to demotivate us from
continuing to be hungry to go and get it
again
or to go and get it more and
that's wrong that's not the way it works
because you're only ever going to
achieve what you're going to achieve
and whether you decide to frame that as
i've done well or i haven't done enough
it doesn't matter
and the line between being tough enough
to
motivate yourself to go forward and
compassionate enough
to be grateful for the things that
you've done is far wider than most
people
realize how do you personally approach
this problem do you often think about
death
yeah i do um not always in the perfectly
stoic sort of memento mori way sometimes
i just fear it
you know i've got two parents and i'm an
only child
so you know when one of those passes i'm
not going to have a brother or sister
who's going to be able to support me
like i fear i fear them passing i've
never had to deal with anyone dying
before
um the biggest thing that i think
one of the biggest changes that's
reframed life for me
has just been realizing quite how
short it truly is um
anyone that wants to swallow the red
pill on this hard
sam harris death in the present moment
uh it's a 20-minute talk that's been
edited on youtube
and it's got background music behind it
from a talk that he gave a few years ago
um and basically he says that our minds
are consumed with things that don't
really matter
and we only realize this too late we
know that when we look back
we'll constantly detest the things that
consumed our attention on day-to-day
basis and we all know that this is
coming
and you can do this you can work this
out quite easily
by thinking what have i done over the
last week that i'm going to remember
when i'm
on my deathbed and if there's nothing
there what the [ __ ] are you doing
like why are we here the only
way the only reason that we are here
is to live a life that we in retrospect
are grateful that we lived the present
moment is something that we need to
exist in right now
because that's all that there is but
oddly the present moment is incredibly
fleeting
and it's only in respect that we
actually live our lives
but when people say i can't believe that
time is moving so quickly life's going
so fast
they don't mean that time moves
relativistically it's always at the same
time for you it's moving at the same
pace
you have the same number of hours now as
you did when you were four years old
when life seemed to go so slowly what
was the difference it was the way that
you framed your experience it was a
number of new novel and intense things
that you did on a day-to-day basis
it was your learner's mind it was the
fact that you approached things with a
beginner sense
that's within your power right now you
have
the chance the opportunity today
tomorrow
for the rest of your life to sink
yourself into the moment-to-moment
experience of whatever it is that you're
doing
to do in the present what you in the
future
will be happy that you did as opposed to
something that you're going to regret
yeah that makes complete sense i'm
completely aligned with you here how do
you
personally do that because you have this
project that you're building right what
is the life goal for you what is your
purpose on earth what would you say
i got a good example for that so we hit
100 000 subscribers on youtube recently
and that was a goal that we've been
working toward for a long time
and i sat down with my video guy who's
the only other person that's a part of
this project and we were talking about
what are our goals for 2021 and
immediately both of us fell into the
quantifiable metrics of success hedonic
adaptation game
oh well if we can get to 250k by sort of
october time maybe that'll be 300 by
december
and then that means that we've got a
good chance of hitting one mill by like
22 by the end of 2022
i'm thinking to myself like this isn't
even 2021 and i'm planning about the
thing i want
by the by 2023. um
so i kind of like shook my head it's
like it's like when
sort of flies around your head when
you're away on a holiday and somewhere
hot
and you kind of need to just get rid of
them these sort of
ego driven base
very primitive thoughts and
i sat down with dean again i had another
conversation i was like man like we
should have
one goal one goal simply
and that is to produce the best
quality videos and podcasts that we can
if
all that we're doing is providing as
much insight
as we can on a week by week basis the
performance and everything else will
look after itself it doesn't matter
none of the other stuff matters and i
think that focusing
it's cliche to say but for anyone that
needs reminding of it
the process is all that matters there is
no destination there is only the journey
there
in a very very very real way if you
don't know what i'm talking about just
google hedonic adaptation
and it will come up straight away but
you're not going to be satisfied when
you reach the thing
you're going to feel satisfied on the
way to the thing
and it's never ever ever going to change
so my goal is to
provide the best insight that i can
there's a few ways
i do that i like to come up with novel
ideas i like to challenge people i like
to make them feel uncomfortable because
it forces them
to address their own assumptions about
the world i like to be compassionate
i think that um using a colorful
vocabulary
is a beautiful way articulating yourself
in a precise
and erudite manner is a very wonderful
way to brighten people's lives the
sort of people that i want to reach out
to i want people to feel like they're
not alone i want them to feel like i'm
vulnerable too
and it's okay and it's a part of being a
human and it's not
signaling that i want their sympathy
it's simply
letting them know that there are other
people out there who feel precisely the
same way that they do
a man like if i do that [ __ ] the
subscribers like it doesn't matter
i don't care because i would sooner take
10 people's lives changed than 10
million subscribers
and i know that i know that in my heart
of hearts and i just need to keep coming
back to that every time
every time i open the youtube studio app
to check how many more subscribers i've
got today
i just need to remind myself nah that's
not the metric you're not going to see
how many people's lives you've impacted
but remember that that's the process
remember that that's the goal
you